okay it's some people's favorite day of
the week it is time for hatred male hey
let's face it the only logical response
to guns is more freaking guns Patriot
male written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom
okay this sometimes I need to provide
context to hatred mail sometimes I need
some kind of introduction sometimes I
need to define terms and speak a little
bit at length this week I don't need to
do that we're gonna go right into hatred
mail and I'm gonna need help I think
figuring out what this one means boy
David having allergic reactions to the
air like the weakling cookie is I wonder
how his girlfriend felt about that such
a cut immune system no surprise he ended
up in San Francisco the epitome of Chuck
central what with the disgusting sexual
debauchery they're famous for San Fran
takes cut to a whole new level
the most notable element that
distinguishes this hatred mail from 99%
of hatred mail is that the vocabulary
actually used words that are not usually
in the parlance of the hatred
particularly the word debauchery so that
you know take it for what it's worth but
that that's a that's a distinguishing
factor in some way right yeah and I love
the reverb on the David portion of it
yeah so for people who don't know why
that was there the my name was in triple
parentheses which is this way that I
guess it's a white supremacist thing on
the internet where you've identified
Jews without saying Jewish David Pakman
by a triple parenthesis and the hatred
interpretation of that is to read it
with present it with some reverb and I
think that that is a really really great
thing send a middle finger to the hay
tree it's by using the coupon code hay
tree at 40 when you sign up for
membership if you go to join pakman.com
and when checking out you type in the
coupon code hey tree at 40 you get 40%
off and six hey tree it's cry which is a
really really great thing for a lot of
people